this is good because now this is one of
our first interviews and by the end
we're gonna be really on our musical
knowledge some like it hot
no no it's um no I don't know 42nd
Street
I don't maybe it was Annie Get Your Gun
never would've a letter
[Music]
alright Jake remember ladies it's a boy
so I get bonus point to the boys t-birds
yes you know the I didn't go to theater
school I'll see ya you know the yep you
know it's Romeo genius Oh Oh Mamma Mia
and him Oh lame is yes
ha it is slave is yeah wicked yeah
correct
[Music]
yeah never saw it it's wrong about it we
who either ones that once mean you
started singing the song here estimate
reference Chester we start seeing song
he thought was from chess he looked at
us blankly and then he walked away and
realized it wasn't from chess he just
sang a song Tim I don't even know what
it's from it was just he looks like yeah
when I saw that it was at my local
cinema and me and my friend that went
were like the only people in there and
then I was like a big kind of like flat
platform and we like Scott onto the
platform and just danced along to the
entire film it was amazing and I think I
think by the end someone came is that
you need to sit down it was incredible
what are your favorite musicals I love
cabaret Hamilton is a work of genius oh
my god you must I know I know I know you
know we should go we should go right now
we're gonna
[Laughter]
Hey greatest showmen yes I know exactly
what that is
i'm karis I don't know I get Guys and
Dolls yeah sad story that story this is
the final question this is gonna be the
decider one could do quite even to 2008
June 23rd July 23rd July 26th luckily by
the stay a day and then whoever's closer
when July 23rd July 16th it's so crazy
it's very the 10 years exactly the 10
years and 10 days 10 years and Denise
that's it that's that's it it is crazy
because I remember watching it so
clearly yeah I'm really really like
cereal